uh talk to me about your relationship
with usa basketball
i don't have one
um
yeah i don't have one um
i'm happy for them i when chelsea and
especially nafisa collier are my two
that i'm i'm really close with
you know i don't have one and i think it
goes from the fact that
i think that when you evolve with time
that's when you're at your best and i
don't know if usa basketball has
continually evolved with time um
and then also i also believe that there
are so many times where
just
tell me and then i won't waste my time
like if that was the stipulations and so
i think it was very interesting
for me personally
to
have a situation where
i went to a camp
i got a triple-double at the camp
was i think first or second in scoring
like it wasn't on the court yeah so if
it's me as an individual as a person
i'm spending time away from my daughter
to come and do these camps that i'm not
even being judged off of how i'm playing
what do you think you're judged off i
don't think i personally fit i don't
think gina wanted me on the team so i
think it's one of those things where
it's like cool like just tell me and
then don't you know
beat around the bush like just tell
people and so
i think now we're reaching a point where
players are becoming more empowered and
i've said this about the nba for a very
very very long time they started
becoming and i know the nba has been a
process but when the way that they
empower their players
where they have a voice they have a say
they talk to them they're honest with
things like the way in which they handle
nba
basketball
usa basketball like there's some people
it didn't matter
they were untouchable like you know what
i mean
and so i think that
based off of like i knew as soon as he
was named the coach again i was like oh
well
so he's gonna be interested why do you
think that is why do you think he did
not want candace parker on the team i
mean we he doesn't like me i don't like
him i mean we don't like each other but
i think i am of the mindset and this is
where i think sometimes i get
misunderstood a little bit i'm of the
mindset that like i don't have to like
you to play with you i don't have to
like you to work with you
you know yeah and it's fine like it's
cool they they made their decision um i
laugh and joke that my kids will never
play usa basketball or usa sports at all
but listen it's a thing of the past
but i'm one of those people that's like
i get more angry at the people i love
getting hurt and what they did in neca
was
unbelievable yeah she deserved it's one
of those things where it's like
i'm more angry at that
because you have somebody that arguably
maybe
2016 but definitely she's the only mvp
of the league
you know what i mean she went and got i
think mvp of the world games and then
you leave her off the team
and so i think that there's you know
certain grace for certain people
and there's certain things that aren't
that you don't get grace yeah there's no
consistency listen
respect to connecticut connecticut
continues to crank out
player of the year after player of the
year right
um
at the same time though like when i was
there my four years at tennessee they
didn't win no national championships
talk it talk
they never beat us but yeah i don't know
like that might be a soft spot i don't
know
and he was like because
she wasn't yeah because they couldn't
get this she's
when we were there okay no i'm just
kidding but listen like
totally i just said because they called
back in 2000 to go for 2020 and i was
like
no like i'm not yeah it's like you're
not doing this did what you did it's
like i just can't i can't teach my
daughter lessons and tell her about you
know respect and treatment and
communication all this stuff and then go
back to that so i just i'm done i'm
happy i got two gold medals i appreciate
the experience um
and i wish them well honestly like i'm
so proud of chelsea and nafisa and you
know obviously sue and diana what they
did in terms of going to five olympics
and winning five medals like that's
super special and i think it's valuable
um
and it's important for usa to stay on
top